if russia will be if russia
faces such a threat as the admission of ukraine to the
north atlantic fan alliance, then the
threats to our country will increase many times
because there
is article 5 of the treaty on the creation of a need in
which it is clear that all the countries of the
alliance must fight or on the side of
one of their members  if
it is subjected to some kind of aggression, but
since no one recognizes the
will of the Crimeans and Sevastopol residents,
Ukraine insists that this is its
territory, we have a real
threat to some NATO countries
against Ukraine becoming a member of the
alliance, however, despite the fact that they are
against  In 2008, in Bucharest, they signed a
memorandum that opens up a tree for Ukraine and
Georgia over my question why
does he want and did the answer no
pressure from the United States, this is the
answer,
but if they made one ball under the
pressure of the United States where we have a
guarantee that they will not do it and 2 steps  under
pressure, well, about the initiatives of the
President macron, but about  holding the
Putin Biden summit and then the totally
five themselves with the invitation of some other
states, or separate groups of
states on international
security issues, European security
present macron really spoke on these topics in two
yesterday's Sunday conversations with
President Putin
, but
President Putin explained very clearly and
he explained more than once that we are not against
summits, not against meetings, but before
meeting especially in such a tense
atmosphere, it is important to understand how
these summits will end and what the result will be,
therefore, the
leaders of Russia and France agreed
that our Western colleagues who
initiate such events will
present  us our vision of their possible
results, we are waiting for the purpose of our race
today's meeting is
to listen to colleagues and
determine our further steps in this
direction, bearing in mind the appeal of the
leaders of the
Donetsk People's Republic and the Luhansk
People's Republic  of the public to Russia with a request for
recognition of sovereignty and a
resolution of the
State Duma of the Russian
Federation on the same topic